Peu importe à quel point vous êtes bons,
ce qui compte c'est à quel point vous le deviendrez.
J'ai visité cette maternité au Nord de l'Inde.
Je regardais les sages-femmes,
et j'ai pris conscience que j'étais témoin d'une forme extrême de cette lutte,
qui fait que les gens s’améliorent face à la complexité -
ou pas.
Les femmes ici accouchent dans une région
où le taux de mortalité des nouveaux-nés est d'1/20 dans une maternité type,
et le taux de mortalité des mères est 10 fois supérieur à la normale.
Or, nous connaissons les pratiques essentielles
qui mettent fin à la mortalité néonatale depuis des années
mais même dans cet endroit -
surtout dans cet endroit,
les choses les plus simples ne le sont pas.
On sait qu'on doit se laver les mains et mettre des gants propres,
mais là,
le robinet est dans une autre pièce,
et elles n'ont pas de gants propres.
Pour réutiliser les gants,
elles les lavent dans cette bassine d'eau diluée avec de l'eau de javel,
mais vous voyez qu'il reste du sang de l'accouchement précédent sur les gants.
Partout, 10 % des enfants naissent avec des difficultés respiratoires.
Nous savons quoi faire.
Vous séchez le bébé avec un linge propre pour le stimuler à respirer.
S'ils ne respirent toujours pas,
on libère les voies respiratoires.
Et si ça ne fonctionne pas, vous leur mettez un masque à oxygène.
Mais ça, ce sont des compétences apprises principalement dans les livres,
et ce masque à oxygène est cassé.
Sur cette image dérangeante
on voit une photo qui montre à quel point la situation est grave.
Voici un bébé né il y a 10 minutes,
et il est en vie,
mais respire à peine.
Il n'a pas de draps propres,
n'a pas été séché,
personne n'est là pour le réchauffer,
et il porte une pince non stérilisée autour du cordon.
Il risque d'attraper une infection,
et sa température baisse de minute en minute.
La réussite d'un accouchement dépend d'une équipe médicale performante.
L'équipe doit être compétente et coordonnée ;
les infirmières qui font accoucher dans un endroit pareil,
les docteurs qui les assistent,
le gestionnaire qui doit s'assurer que les 22 médicaments et fournitures
sont en stock et au chevet du patient,
le praticien hygiéniste en chef,
responsable de la qualité de l'établissement.
Ce sont tous des professionnels aguerris.
Les personnes que j'ai rencontré ont déjà pratiqué des milliers d'accouchements.
Mais face aux difficultés qu'elles rencontrent,
elles ont atteint leurs limites.
Elles ne s'amélioraient plus.
Ce qui importe vraiment, c'est à quel point vous excellerez.
Cela soulève une question fondamentale.
Comment les professionnels s'améliorent-ils dans ce qu'ils font ?
Comment excellent-ils ?
Il existe deux points de vue.
Le premier est le point de vue pédagogique traditionnel.
Celui où vous allez à l'école,
vous étudiez, vous pratiquez, vous apprenez, vous obtenez un diplôme,
puis vous entrez dans la vie active
et vous faites vos preuves.
Un professionnel est quelqu'un capable de s’améliorer par lui-même.
C'est l'approche théorique apprise par tous les professionnels.
Les médecins l'apprennent,
les avocats,
les scientifiques...
les musiciens.
Et ça fonctionne.
Prenez l'exemple du professeur de violon du conservatoire Julliard, Dorothy DeLay.
Elle a formé un panel incroyable de violonistes virtuoses :
Midori, Sarah Chang, Itzhak Perlman.
Tous l'ont sollicitée comme jeunes talents,
et ont travaillé des années avec elle.
En insistant le plus, disait-elle,
sur la transmission des habitudes mentales et d'apprentissage
qui leur permettraient de réussir seuls
une fois la formation terminée.
Dans le monde du sport le point de vue est opposé.
Ils disent : « On n'a jamais fini,
tout le monde a besoin d'un coach. »
Tout le monde.
Les meilleurs au monde ont besoin d'un coach.
J'ai donc essayé d'y penser en tant que chirurgien.
Payer quelqu'un qui viendrait dans ma salle d'opération,
m'observerait et me critiquerait.
Ça semble absurde.
L'expertise signifie ne pas avoir besoin d'un coach.
Ainsi quelle opinion est la bonne ?
J'ai appris que le coaching sportif est une idée très américaine.
En 1875,
Harvard et Yale ont joué un des tous premiers matchs de football américain.
Yale a embauché un entraîneur en chef ;
Harvard ne l'a pas fait.
Le résultat ?
Sur les trois décennies suivantes,
Harvard a gagné seulement quatre fois.
Harvard a embauché un entraîneur en chef.
(Rires)
Et c'est devenu la manière de fonctionner du sport.
Mais est-ce donc nécessaire ?
Est-ce transférable dans d'autres domaines ?
J'ai donc choisi de demander
à Itzhak Perlman.
Il s'est entrainé à la manière de Dorothy Delay
et est devenu indéniablement le meilleur violoniste de sa génération.
Une des plus belles choses sur le fait d'écrire pour Le New Yorker,
c'est que lorsque j'appelle des gens, ils me rappellent.
(Rires)
Et Perlman m'a rappelé.
Et nous avons discuté pendant presque deux heures
sur la façon dont il est parvenu à connaître un tel succès.
Et je lui ai demandé : « Pourquoi les violonistes n'ont-ils pas de coach ? »
Et il a répondu : « Je ne sais pas,
mais j'ai toujours eu un coach. »
« Vous avez toujours eu un coach ? »
« Oh oui, ma femme, Toby. »
Ils ont obtenu leurs diplômes ensemble à Juilliard,
et elle a abandonné son travail de violoniste d'orchestre
pour être son coach,
s'asseoir dans l'audience,
l'observer et lui faire un feedback.
« Itzhak, au milieu de cette partie,
ça sonnait un peu de façon mécanique.
Que pourrais-tu faire différemment la prochaine fois ? »
C'était essentiel à son devenir, dit-il.
Il s'est avéré qu'il y a de nombreuses difficultés à le faire soi-même.
Vous ne voyez pas les problèmes qui vous font obstacle
et si vous le faites,
vous ne savez pas toujours comment y remédier.
Et le résultat est qu'à un moment donné,
vous cessez de vous améliorer.
J'ai réfléchi à ça,
et j'ai réalisé que c'était ce qui m'était arrivé en tant que chirurgien.
J'ai commencé à opérer en 2003,
et pendant les premières années,
je m'améliorais de façon constante.
Les taux de complications ont chuté d'année en année.
Et au bout de cinq ans,
ils se sont stabilisés.
Et quelques années après ça,
j'ai réalisé que je ne m'améliorais plus.
Et je me suis dit : « Est-ce tout ce dont je suis capable ? »
J'ai réfléchi un peu plus et je me suis dit :
« Ok,
je vais embaucher un coach. »
J'ai donc demandé à un de mes anciens professeurs qui avait pris sa retraite,
il s'appelle Bob Osteen,
et il a accepté de venir dans ma salle d'opération
et de m'observer.
L'opération -
je m'en rappelle encore.
Tout s'est passé à merveille.
Je ne pensais pas qu'il aurait quoi que ce soit à ajouter
quand nous avions terminé.
A la place, il avait une page entière de prise de notes.
(Rires)
« C'est pas grand chose », dit-il.
Mais ce sont les plus petits détails qui comptent.
« As-tu remarqué que la lumière a cessé d'éclairer la plaie
pendant l'opération ?
Tu as passé environ 30 minutes
à opérer à partir de la lumière provenant de surfaces réfléchissantes. »
« Autre chose », dit-il,
« Tes coudes remontent de temps en temps.
Ce qui veut dire que tu n'est pas totalement stable.
Les coudes d'un chirurgien devraient être souples et au niveau de la taille.
Ce qui veut dire que si tu sens tes coudes se lever,
tu devrais prendre un autre instrument, ou juste bouger tes pieds. »
C'était un tout autre niveau de prise de conscience.
Et je me suis dit,
tu sais, il y a quelque chose de vraiment important à propos de cela.
Il décrivait ce que font les meilleurs coachs,
ils sont vos yeux et vos oreilles,
vous donnant une vision plus juste de votre réalité.
Ils reconnaissent ce qui est essentiel.
Ils décortiquent vos actions
et vous aident à les reconstruire.
Après deux mois de coaching,
j'ai senti que je m'améliorais de nouveau.
Et au bout d'un an,
j'ai vu mes taux de complications chuter encore plus.
C'était douloureux.
Je n'aimais pas être observé
et parfois je n'avais pas envie de travailler sur les détails.
J'ai aussi ressenti qu'à certains moments je reculerais pour mieux avancer.
Mais cela m'a fait réaliser
que les coachs avaient une dimension profondément importante.
Dans mon emploi précédent,
j'ai dirigé un centre de santé et d'innovation appelé Ariadne Labs,
où nous travaillions sur des problèmes liés à l'obtention de soins de santé,
incluant les soins à l'accouchement.
Dans ce cadre,
nous avons travaillé avec l'OMS
afin de créer une check-list pour les accouchements.
Ça a déterminé l'essentiel.
Ça a questionné l'essentiel -
les actions cruciales par lesquelles une équipe doit passer
lorsqu'une femme se met en travail,
quand elle est prête à pousser,
quand le bébé est sorti,
puis quand la mère et l'enfant sont prêts à rentrer chez eux.
Et nous savions
que le fait d'établir une check-list n'allait pas changer grand chose
et que même le fait de l'enseigner dans une salle de classe ne suffirait pas
à inciter les gens à créer les changements dont on aurait besoin pour la concrétiser.
Et j'ai pensé à mon expérience et je me suis dit,
« Et si nous essayions le coaching ?
Et si nous essayions le coaching à grande échelle ? »
Nous avons trouvé des partenaires incroyables,
incluant le gouvernement indien,
et nous l'avons testé dans 120 centres,
en Uttar Pradesh, le plus grand état de l'Inde.
Nous avons seulement observé une moitié des centres,
et des coachs sont venus dans l'autre moitié.
Nous avons entrainé une armée de médecins et d'infirmières comme elle
qui ont appris à observer les soins ainsi que les managers
et nous les avons aidés à améliorer leurs forces
et à dépasser leurs faiblesses.
Une des compétences qu'ils devaient améliorer dans l'équipe
et qui s'est avérée être essentielle
fut la communication.
Inciter les infirmières à communiquer quand le masque à oxygène est cassé,
qu'il n'y a plus de gants,
que quelqu'un ne se lave pas les mains.
Et encourager les autres, managers inclus,
à pratiquer l'écoute.
Cette petite armée de coachs a fini par former 400 infirmières
et autres sages-femmes
ainsi que 100 physiciens et managers.
Nous avons suivi les résultats parmi 160 000 naissances.
Les résultats
du groupe témoin -
et ce sont ceux qui n'ont pas eu de coachs -
ont donné naissance en utilisant seulement un tiers des 18 pratiques de base
que l'on évaluait.
Et le plus important s'est passé durant l'année de l'étude,
on n'a observé aucune amélioration dans la durée.
Les autres ont eu quatre mois de coaching,
les pratiques ont diminué pendant huit mois
et on les a vu augmenter
de plus de 2/3 lors des soins pratiqués.
Ça a fonctionné.
On a pu voir l'amélioration de la qualité des soins
et on a pu l'observer parmi une grande variété de centres
qui suggérait que le coaching pouvait être nouvelle manière
d'apporter une plus-value à ce que l'on fait.
On peut imaginer la diversité des emplois concernés dans le monde
et que des millions de personnes pourraient combler.
Cependant, nous en étions aux prémices
car il y avait encore du chemin à parcourir.
Il faut remplir l'ensemble de la check-list
pour réduire la mortalité de façon conséquente.
Mais nous avons vu les premiers centres qui allaient dans cette direction
et ce centre était l'un d'entre eux
car le coaching les a aidé à apprendre à appliquer les bases.
Et on pouvait le voir ici.
Voici une femme de 23 ans
qui est arrivée ici en ambulance,
en travail avec son troisième enfant.
Elle a perdu les eaux dans la zone de triage,
ils l'ont donc amenée directement dans la salle d'accouchement
puis ont parcouru la check-list.
Je mets l'image sur pause ici
afin de vous montrer à quelle vitesse tout se passe
et à quel point cela rend les choses compliquées.
En quatre minutes,
elles avaient pris la tension, mesuré le pouls
et avaient aussi vérifié les battements du cœur du bébé.
Ce qui signifiait que le tensiomètre et le Doppler fœtal
étaient prêts et l'infirmière a su les utiliser.
L'équipe était compétente et coordonnée.
La mère se portait bien,
les battements du cœur du bébé était à 143, ce qui est normal.
Huit minutes plus tard, l'intensité des contractions a augmenté,
l'infirmière s'est donc lavé les mains,
mis des gants propres,
l'a examinée et a vu que son col était complètement dilaté.
Le bébé était prêt à sortir.
Elle est ensuite allée directement vérifier la suite de sa check-list.
Elle a rassemblé tous les équipements
et s'est assurée d'avoir tout ce dont elle avait besoin.
Le masque à oxygène, la serviette stérile,
l'équipement stérile dont on a besoin.
Puis trois minutes plus tard, une poussée et le bébé était là.
(Applaudissements)
Je regardais cet accouchement
et j'ai réalisé aussitôt que l'atmosphère dans cette salle avait changé.
L'infirmière regardait l'agent de santé communautaire
qui était entré avec la femme
car ce bébé semblait mort.
Elle était bleue, flasque et ne respirait pas.
Elle serait l'une de ces 1/20 enfants morts à la naissance.
Mais l'infirmière a continué de parcourir sa check-list.
Elle a séché ce bébé avec une serviette propre.
Et au bout d'une minute alors que le bébé ne bougeait pas,
elle a couru pour attraper le masque à oxygène
et l'autre sage-femme a dégagé les voies respiratoires.
Elle n'avait pas d'aspirateur à mucosités car cela dépend de l'électricité,
elle a pris l'appareil buccal
et en 20 secondes,
elle avait libéré les voies respiratoires de cette petite fille.
Et elle a sorti un liquide vert et épais
et en l'espace d'une minute à faire ça,
à aspirer encore et encore,
le bébé a commencé à respirer.
(Applaudissements)
Une minute plus tard et le bébé pleurait.
Et cinq minutes après ça,
elle était rose et se réchauffait sur la poitrine de sa mère
et cette mère a attrapé la main de l'infirmière
et ils ont tous pu respirer.
J'ai vu une équipe se transformer grâce au coaching.
Et j'ai vu au moins une vie être sauvée grâce à ça.
Nous avons surveillé cette mère quelques mois plus tard.
La mère et l'enfant se portaient bien.
La petite fille s'appelle Anshika.
Ça signifie « magnifique ».
Et elle représente ce qui est possible
quand nous comprenons réellement
la façon dont les gens s'améliorent dans ce qu'ils font.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)